des questions on vous trouve l'info vous
sentez-vous parfois espionné par votre
voisin les caméras de surveillance
résidentiels sont de plus en plus
populaire et vous n'avez peut-être pas
envie qu'on enregistre aux allées et
venues pauline de gatineau nous
demandent comment s'assurer que ces
caméras ne constitue pas une atteinte à
la vie privée
[Musique]
selon le code civil une atteinte à la
vie privée d'une personne sait capter ou
utiliser son image où sa voix
lorsqu'elle se trouve dans les lieux
privés
on ne parle pas ici du stationnement
d'un immeuble à condos mais de la cour
arrière de votre unifamiliales par
exemple notre journaliste à la recherche
a parlé à pierre trudel experts du droit
de l'information et la protection de la
vie privée mais votre voisin a aussi un
droit le droit à la sécurité
si votre voisin refusent de coopérer les
tribunaux peuvent trancher entre votre
besoin est le sien mais avant d'en
arriver là
heureusement il y à la médiation vous
aurez la chance de lui faire voir le
problème sous votre angle à vous
[Musique]